como una decisión sin fundamentos
calificó el ministerio de exteriores
francés la decisión de rusia expulsar
hoy a 34 diplomáticos franceses de moscú
esta mañana pierde y el embajador de
francia en la capital la rusa fue
convocado por el ministerio de
exteriores de ese país que le comunicó
que 34 de sus funcionarios serán
declarados persona 'non grata' y que
tenían 15 días para dejar el país moscú
explicó en ese momento que esta decisión
es en represalia la expulsión en abril
pasado de 41 diplomáticos rusos desde
parís en ese momento las autoridades de
inteligencia francesas decretaron que
estas personas estaban realizando más
bien tareas de espionaje escondidas como
tareas diplomáticas sin embargo parís
dice que sus funcionarios han cumplido
en todo momento con la convención de
viena que es la que rige el trabajo
diplomático los analistas piensan que
generan la respuesta de moscú a france
ha sido bastante moderada pues son 34
funcionarios franceses y no 41 como los
rusos y además son personas más bien de
un perfil técnico y no esenciales en el
trabajo de la embajada lo cierto es que
hoy también rusia ha decido expulsar
cuatro diplomáticos italianos de 27
españoles